hi I'm Eric Voss and the new fourth
season of black mirror on Netflix says
raise the bar on making old Souls like
me even more afraid of Technology hate
that cloud yeah it's in the midst of all
this high concept psychological torture
porn showrunner Charlie Brooker has
included a few uplifting less bleak
standouts like last season San Junipero
and the seasons hang the DJ which
focuses on a couple who meets in a
dating service with preset expiration
dates or expiry dates I'm gonna explain
this mind-bending twist ending the
significance of the song choice and a
few other interesting details from this
episode that you might have missed and
of course spoilers ahead for hanging DJ
and all the black bear episodes that
came before it okay so in hang the DJ
Frank and Amy meet over a series of
encounters through the mysterious dating
app known as the system which brings
them together but also sticks them with
other random pairings each with varying
ranges of expiry dates that is until
they realize they're part of a massive
simulation the apps rumoured ninety nine
point eight percent success rate
actually refers to the number of times
various digital versions of Frank and
Amy were brought together and out of
nine hundred ninety eight of a thousand
of those simulations the pair
successfully rebelled against the system
to escape together the episodes final
scene reveals that those successful
simulations translate to the ninety nine
point eight percent score that the
Afghan Frank and Amy's real-life Perry
basically this is like OK Cupid or
tinder with 1000 digital simulations of
yourself meeting a partner and 998 of
those simulations defied Authority
risking a horrible fate just to be
together suggesting that your odds of
hitting it off and real-life must be
pretty good and to be clear even though
those digital versions of Frank and Amy
are similar to these sentient digital
clones and USS Callister or the trapped
consciousnesses in white Christmas these
aren't the same thing these are
simulated versions of Frank and Amy
within this dating app matched in 1000
simul taneous experiments to produce a
match score slightly less horrific now
for this episode's deeper meaning let's
talk about the title hang the DJ it
comes from the song that we hear playing
in the bar in that final scene with the
real-life Frank and Amy
this is panic by the Smiths the story
behind the song goes that songwriters
Morrissey and Johnny Marr were listening
the radio about the Chernobyl nuclear
disaster and then the DJ randomly
started playing I'm your man by Wham
which is a pretty dumb pop song so the
lyrics burn the disco and hang the
blessed DJ for playing songs that say
nothing to them about their lives
Express that idea of rebellion against a
simple but emotionally hollow system
hang the DJ was actually on Charlie
brookers playlist of soundtrack music
for San Junipero but it didn't make it
into the final episode it's really the
perfect song for digital presences
finding love in a virtual world but this
whole theme of rebellion runs throughout
hang the DJ early in the episode Frank
and Amy praise the system's
simplification of the confusion and
awkwardness of real-life relationships
but admit that a life without free will
feels unnatural that's not what it's all
about Tom cut nice so much simpler and
it's all my pal hmmm this is weird
though it is from the beginning their
relationship is defined by their acts of
rebellion despite not knowing whether
it's allowed they share their meals they
ditch their partners to reconnect at the
engagement party and yeah they
ultimately escape together
most importantly they decide not to look
at their expiry dates the prior
knowledge of how long relationship will
last is essentially the death of that
relationship to instead choose mystery
and unpredictability isn't just an act
of rebellion and free will it's an act
of true love all of these acts of
rebellion are part of the simulation
they're structured opportunities for the
two of them to eventually make their own
choice each other and if you were
looking closely there were actually a
lot of clues that the system is all part
of a simulation first there's the
routine of these characters lives as we
seen in the episode they exist purely
for one purpose to match and rematch
even the time between relationships
they're exercising staying in physical
shape for the next pairing and they
can't remember their lives before this
cycle because those lives didn't exist
another interesting clue was the
skipping stones throughout the episode
Amy skip stones on the pond and at one
point she makes this observation if you
ever had more than four or less than
four that's right every time a character
skips a stone in this simulation it
skips precisely four times number three
number five this is a red flag of this
world's art of
she allottee I also seize the
metaphorical significance here the for
skips not only set up that great
callback of Amy's skipping her coach
device into the pool later the fact that
skips four times could reflect the four
Skip's of Amy and Frank's relationship
these two connect a total of four times
the first 12-hour period then the run in
at the party then the five-year period
and then the final goodbye that turns
into their escape each time their
connection ends abruptly before skipping
to the next one and then finally sinking
in on the final one and I know it could
sound like I'm stretching it but I
really do think this whole episode was
structured as a simulation to encourage
Frank and Amy to connect check out the
system's logo to intersected circles
kind of like a Venn diagram these
circles can join like the couples the
system tries to pair together but later
when Frank and Amy fight and they break
up this upward looking shot looks at the
ceiling design with two huge circles
separate from each other it's like a me
and Frank are going against what the
system really wants also when Amy gets
paired with other men like Lenny and
another match later the framing includes
this wall painting the background
showing a circle intersecting a square
this could reflect how Amy is
essentially a round peg trying to fit
into a square hole meanwhile when Frank
it's disastrously paired with Nicola the
two of them get framed with another
awkward angular shape triangles I think
this all amounts to some clever visual
storytelling depicting the system as a
singing Li heartless authoritarian
structure that is discretely playing
matchmaker for these two loveable
circles coming together as one circle in
the final scene now if encouraging them
to rebel was the systems plan all along
does that mean Frank and Amy truly have
free will huh maybe not dams
let's make me feel good so looking at
the episode in this light here's my
question for you guys does hang the DJ
have a happy ending or a secretly bleak
black mirror style dark ending comment
with your take down below or tweet me
directly at ei vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos like this
video and subscribe the new rock stars
for deep dives and all the stuff you
love stranger things Game of Thrones
Star Wars we got it all here and if you
really like us you can contribute to us
on patreon big thanks to all of our
donors especially Kelly hopper thanks
for watching bye